thank God my grandfather just died so I
blew a curse I made my money the
old-fashioned way I got run over by
Alexis because technically I'm home
where I tell you huh
she's the worst in the world done
Ralphie oh how are you I'm gonna tell
you something that I once heard from a
very very smart woman named Cameron the
lady who waxes you told me if you don't
love what you do how am i doing and she
ripped the hair from my be home
Kate's at the ends of the opp she's the
dumbest little shorty in all Pawnee
Indiana are to the ODE to the end and
then desist once got swagging the size
of Big Ben clock yeah y'all me to write
a rap fail you name yes go B to the O to
the SS do what he say and you'll be
successful
[Music]
let's seal this devil's three-way right
here right now step one we buy into this
club step two we roll over to the club
either new Mercedes Benz or my pre-owned
Acura Legend step three I heard you on
the dance floor just bounce bounce
bounce bounce I know all the ladies had
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce we
stay sexy I'm out
[Music]
yeah little Sharia ah okay rethink that
moves on swats on what am i man are you
kidding me it's like I always say okay
when life gives you lemons you sell some
your grandma's jewelry and you go club
and stop it hey what's up beautiful
jean-ralphio I live in the guest house
what do you say you and I get together
in a special way
I'm pregnant the more merrier with my
baby but you can come too beautiful look
at that I guess sometimes I call men
beautiful - I guess I'm open-minded as
hell I think you're pretty good-looking
thank you I'm gonna throw up I ate too
much cheese I'll just talk about a job
opening because guess who's got two
thumbs and was just clear from insurance
fraud got off on a technicality
I heard sack of flour and high school
are you ding-dongs making fake drugs for
sophomores because if true this guy
wants in I like your energy hombre what
do you say you and I ride go-karts later
I want to go horseback riding deal
jean-ralphio hello hey Andy Andy that's
alright name that's not right name
thank you yeah well this medium drink of
water be there the only reason I
wouldn't be there is if I got pulled
over for violating my house
Oh judge gave me two ankle bracelets it
was the first time he ever had to do
that juh boys a question on the bar exam
I'm gonna John Robie oh yes I'm here
dance up on me yes yes yes
so what's your story again I mean like
how married are you of you down to clown
when that rude mood why are you like
this palace baby this no doubt which one
floats your penis take me there
will you do me one final kindness will
you pretend to be my wife for an
insurance scam but then we're falls in
love for real also can I have a pair of
your gym socks annoying it's not for
anything weird it's just a fetish I have
tummy
I will always be there for you no matter
what the right now I cannot be there for
you because I have to go oh you want the
big dog oh I decided it was the best if
I took my talents elsewhere do you know
what I mean you abandoned your friend
god no he fired me Leslie I've always
loved you I know
you want to come home with me don't you
work at lady Foot Locker
[Music]